FLORIAN LOITSCH: Thanks.
So my name is
Florian, and I want
to present you how to write
Google Apps Scripts in Dart.
So I have only two slides,
and one of them was the title.
Mainly it's because
I want to make
sure you understand the
difference between Google Apps
Script and Google APIs.
So one of them, the
Google App Scripts,
is the scripting
language you use
or the scripts you use to
control Google Drive, Gmail,
spreadsheets, docs, and
so on, and Google APIs is
a RESTful service where
you can access many--
a RESTful API where you can
access many, many more Google
services.
I use both in this talk.
So Google APIs, that's the
REST, and Google Apps Scripts,
that's controlling
the docs, and so on.
So what-- no,
that's not the one.
So what is a Google Apps Script?
So here I have a spreadsheet.
And if we go to
Tools, Script Editor,
we can write a
small script-- let's
say, a spreadsheet app that gets
UI and dot alert "Hello world."
We save it.
This is, somewhere,
the Run button.
Run.
And we have a hello
world on the spreadsheet.
I mean, this is the
easiest thing to do.
So there are two
things we don't like
about the way this is written
with the Google Apps Editor.
One is it's JavaScript--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
--and the second one is--
so, no, no, it's not Dart.
And the second one is it's not
using the editor that we like,
and it's not using
Git, and so on.
So for the first
thing, not using Dart,
we can actually make
that work quite nicely
by using Dart-to-JavaScript
and compiling to JavaScript.
So here I have a demo ready
where it's just compiled
with Dart-to-JavaScript.
And the important
thing here is that when
you compile for
Google Apps Script,
you need to use the
CSP flag, but once you
have that and a few other
things, it kind of works.
And now, the second part we want
is we want to take that code
and actually get
this ready for--
get this deployed
on our scripts.
And for that, I wrote another
app that watches a specific
directory-- so in this case,
the file that it just compiled--
then automatically uploads
it using Google APIs--
so we just use the thing
to connect to the drive--
and then creates a script
on our Google Drive.
So once we do that and we load--
I should load it like this--
and we load the
apps, you can see
there is an add-ons up behind
the work in this add-ons
in Help, and once it
has loaded enough,
it actually adds now a new
menu item that we created.
And when I run this one, we
now run the Dart Hello World.
And I can show you the
actual code for that.
It's here, down there.
And if I changed it, let's
say, "Hello Dartconf."
Save it.
Recompile it.
And watch in the background
the script that uploads.
Once it's compiled,
it automatically
detects that it has been
changed, uploads it again.
And if you now go back
to the spreadsheet,
we can now run that thing again,
and it's now "Hello Dartconf."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So pretty much, that's
the most important thing
about the Google Apps scripting.
It's a very nice
workflow and so on.
But I have prepared
two more demos.
So if we go to the demo 2--
and again, in the background,
I should show this.
If I compile now, it
will automatically
upload in the background--
uploading done.
And if we now--
there it is-- run it
again, we should get--
this is a little bit bigger.
This is now a script that just
modified the columns, and so
on, and set the
background color.
[APPLAUSE]
And the last demo
just shows that it's
not just Google spreadsheets
that we can control.
We can also modify and
create Google Docs.
But let's see that.
So the first thing it's going
to do it will show as a sidebar.
So you can write sidebars.
Those are actually HTML, so
there's a little bit of HTML,
and so on.
So if I now select or
some other things--
some old dialogs--
so this one now
connects back to the server.
Then there's a script that runs,
which is, again, Dart script.
In this case, I
created a document,
and that document now shows us
that we also have a document--
Google Docs that can be
controlled from Dart.
And with that, I
finished my talk.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh yes-- it's not
open source yet,
but I will try to
make that happen.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
Thanks.